thank you for being here thank you for
having me i i want to ask you uh we had
uh daniel radcliffe
uh last night and i i chatted with him
uh briefly and i asked him the same
question but i want to ask you because
it's such an unusual situation
it's the fifth harry potter film yes and
uh
you look back now how old were you when
you did the first one
i auditioned when i was nine and i
started filming when i was 10 11.
is it strange for you because these
movies are ubiquitous you see them on
television
all the time and do you ever come across
yourself in that first film and how does
that feel
quite horrible uh to be honest it's
really um
i mean i guess it's just yeah
very very strange and especially like in
this one there's loads of flashbacks to
the first film
right um so i get to see a lot of that i
guess just
i just seem to have such chubby cheeks
and so it's like a high voice and a big
hair and
yeah you're describing me perfectly
actually
but that's how i think people don't
generally like to look at themselves at
that age i mean everyone else thinks
that you're
a really cute kid in those films but
that's not how you perceive it right
i mean it's kind of hard to explain like
how that feels but i guess like
i don't know if you hear your voice on
if you ever hear your voice taped on an
answer machine you're like oh it's
horrible people can't listen
it's exactly like that but like 20 times
worse yeah although your voice is very
beautiful mine is very grating
i hear mine sometimes i hear a tv set
i'm like hello folks
someone kill that guy um now there are
lots of of course
there's so much merchandising also
associated with this movie there are
lots of harry potter products
what's the strangest thing that you've
seen your face you know uh associated
with what's the strangest product
it's really hard there is so much harry
potter merchandise um
i was in waitrose the other day and i
came across hermione's magic muffins
which i was like wow that's a new one
what is it is it a it's a muffin mix
yeah yeah
exactly it's a muffin mix you don't have
to buy any ingredients it's all in there
and you kind of get these little
stickers with my head on them and you
kind of
put them on right right yeah yeah and
it's strange because are you uh good you
make muffins yourself are you a you know
a good cook
i'm i'm an awful cook i can't be
completely honest no i i am i would
never ever
do that that would be seriously strange
yeah so it's it must be odd you almost
feel like
your face is on it like i'm responsible
for those muffins tasting delicious
yes kind of i guess yeah kind of what
about i know there are harry potter
video games have you played or any of
your friends
or family played the video games yeah um
at the prez junket they had like a room
with the game that's been released so
people kind of go
and try it and stuff and my brother
obviously was brought to tears listening
to me talk about harry potter
went in and was trying the game out and
he came back and i was like oh did you
have a good morning
he was like yeah yeah i've been throwing
benches at you like for hours
that's just like that's just tonight so
your brother can go into a room and just
hurl benches at you
but no one gets hurt it's perfect yeah
that's very nice dear i know there were
action figures as well does your brother
any of your siblings ever
you know get the action figure that
would be very strange that would be
seriously creepy i don't think i would
let them
let them have it i think that's so like
no that would be really weird
really weird it was something i would do
uh
i understand that you you you made a you
and the cast made a very short
harry potter film especially for the
queen's
eighties 80th birthday yeah and then uh
before the you and then you all met her
did you have to take etiquette lessons
and learn how to meet the queen now i
think there are a lot of rules right
well this is the funny thing by the time
i've had all the sort of etiquette of
how i was meant to meet her and i could
only say this and i can say that
to be honest i was kind of glad in the
end that i didn't actually meet her in
the end because
like apparently you know um you can only
dress her as
your majesty and you can't speak to her
unless she speaks to you and that's kind
of little bow you have to do and all of
this stuff that i was like okay
right okay and um i was so nervous about
it i was kind of like actually you know
what
i'll just i'll just look at her or just
sit behind her that's good enough for me
right because you're so afraid of just
am i going to do this the wrong way
if am i going to make a mistake yeah
yeah did she seem like a nice person did
you get a sense of her as a person or
not really you i mean you were in a room
with her but you didn't actually get to
meet her
to be honest she i mean i hope she
enjoyed
the show that we put together she kind
of she didn't really
not that much facial expression going on
she was quite kind of yeah like this i
was like is she enjoying
she is the queen she's not going to you
know raise the roof
oh chewing the butter
[Applause]
high five so you win the whole cast yeah
i know so i was like
yeah i didn't really know but i'm sure
a lot of people in america you you have
a beautiful voice as i said and
and the the the english accent is so i
mean to many americans it sounds
it's it's uh it sounds so distinguished
and you know
it's awful when i come to america i
always feel really
i hate my english accent because it
sounds so kind of like
i don't know it's pretentious i don't
know if that's the word it sounds really
kind of
i don't know so by the end of my stay
here i kind of find that my english is
kind of edging towards american english
what's pretentious is when people affect
an english accent yours is real you
you were allowed to have one there were
people like madonna who like two years
ago
sort of be like oh hello
aren't you from long island or something
what about um do you uh do you think
that when you hear americans
because they're american actors who in
movies try and do a british accent does
do and to us maybe it sounds all right
but how does it sound to someone you
always tell
you can always tell pretty much i mean
yeah you can pretty much say
it's next to impossible for an american
to do it correctly yeah well i guess i
don't know how well we pull off american
accents though so
you know i think you laurie in in you
know actually yeah
you have to watch that a couple of times
amazing i
cannot believe that he's not from
america yeah quintessentially british
yes very you know i shot something with
him
uh uh for the emmys about a year ago and
he was doing the american accent the
whole time and then
i saw him later on and he was talking in
the british accent and i really thought
this man is ill
he's schizophrenic he's so scary
talented no you're very tired but you
know
when americans go over and and try and
do it a lot of times it sounds like
you know uh you know mary poppins kind
of hello
yeah that's exactly it how you doing you
know
i'm your chimney sweet boy
how i would do it now of course you
and and daniel and rupert you're the the
three uh
main you know uh characters that we've
we've been following
uh throughout these different films uh
have the three of you
and and i don't want to be a crass
question but you've you know you've been
making some money over the years if any
of you gone a little money
a little mad and bought yourself
something crazy or you know just to
treat yourself
i i can't compete with this rupert
bought an ice cream truck
i'm not even keep on an ice cream truck
that is every kid's fantasies
literally no one really does that he's
like he says to me quite seriously he
said if i hadn't got this
you know if i hadn't become an actor you
know i i seriously would have considered
being an ice cream man
i was like okay cool well so he's kind
of like
fulfilled both dreams you know that's
that's so funny and so sweet too at the
same time and as well it's not just like
he's bought the truck to kind of drive
around kind of a show
it actually has all of the ice cream in
it all of like the little chocolate
drops and everything
well i hope it had ice cream in it yeah
well yeah maybe like cool ice cream
truck what's in there
medical books
uh we have a uh we have a clip here from
the film harry potter and the order of
the phoenix
and i want to make sure we show this uh
what uh what do we need to do to or know
to appreciate this clip
you have to see the last film and you
have to know that um
ron was a complete idiot to be fair he
didn't invite her to the ball and then
he made a really big deal about her
going with someone else
and he completely ruined her evening and
she ended up crying up on the steps and
then
he never apologized and basically was
just you know so in this one
she um she kind of kicks his ass she
really does
she really like gets her own back and um
it's quite kind of
a classic uh girl power moment yeah
women everywhere will appreciate this
let's take a look at this moment from
harry potter
and the order of the phoenix i'll go
easier
thanks roland
come on come on come on
one circle you're on
[Music]
it's completely intentional
that's how i would handle that moment
that was on purpose i did it on purpose
uh harry potter and the order of the
phoenix is in theaters uh right now
really a pleasure chatting with you yeah
we hope to see you soon emma watson
everybody paton oswald coming up stick
around we'll be right back